Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg will
testify tomorrow before Congress on how
his company handles its users data
lawmakers returned to a busy week on
Capitol Hill after more than two weeks
on recess but recess is coming again
they only have 14 more working days
until both houses take another break
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning Zuckerberg is
going to try to smooth the way today for
those upcoming hearings by meeting
one-on-one with key lawmakers and we're
told that his message is going to be one
of contrition he'll apologize for the
conditions that enabled a political
consulting firm Cambridge analytic to
access personal data from up to 87
million users and he'll apologize for
the fact that the affected users are
only being alerted on Facebook starting
today over two years later now
Zuckerberg is not the only one getting
grilled this week former Congressman
Mike Pompeo is going to be questioned
about how he'd run the State Department
differently than Rex Tillerson who only
lasted about 14 months no hearing date
has been set yet for Pompey owes
proposed replacement at the helm of the
CIA her name is Gina Haspel or for the
president's pick to run the VA White
House dr. Ronnie Jackson these
confirmations take a lot of time on the
calendar and there are many senators who
are frustrated at the turnover they're
seeing at the cabinet level this quickly
and that may be a part of the reason
Gale that the president has not let go
of another embattled cabinet level
officer the director of the EPA Scott
Pruett in fact the president tweeted
again this weekend that Pruitt is doing
a great job okay
so far so good I guess thank you very
much Nancy